another team that is dealing with an
issue at quarterback is the Tennessee
Titans and there was development
yesterday that makes the situation in
Tennessee big cat very interesting Ryan
Tannehill has now hired CAA which also
represents Derek Henry the star running
back who is due to become a free agent
they got one franchise tag to use these
two guys are now bound together and I
believe the message to management is
going to be neither guy is signing a new
contract until you apply the franchise
tag to one of them meaning that the
other one will get to test the market
now there's a chance the other one gets
a transition tagged if there isn't a new
CBA because if there isn't a new CBA by
March 18 every team gets a franchise tag
and a transition tag transition tag is
meaningless though it's just a right to
match you don't get compensation so if
they transition tag Tannehill or Henry
the guy still gets to go to the market
and see what's out there now that
they're represented by the same agency
and I'm told one of the big factors for
Tannehill and picking CAA was that they
have Derrick Henry there's an
opportunity to put the Titans in
checkmate a little bit as it comes to
these two guys if they say we're not
signing either guy to a long term
contract until you use the franchise tag
on one of them yeah this is kind of a
weird situation because I was walking
through the progression and every single
you know it's Ryan Tannehill has an
agent
they've been negotiating with the Titans
for the last two months they've been
talking about the future
he then fires his agent goes to CAA
Derrick Henry also CAA so you're saying
okay now he's got all the power
but Ryan Tannehill exact agent is also
the GM's agent in Nashville so what like
now the powers back with the GM because
you'd have to think they would get a
deal done if they share the same agent
the whole thing's a little confusing I
would I would guess that the Titans are
gonna give Ryan Tannehill like a 2/3
year thing because he's the type of guy
that even though he was great last year
he still has a lot of body of work
that's not so great
so to throw like big time money big time
years at Ryan Tannehill probably isn't
the smartest decision and guess what to
throw big time money in big time years
at a running back also not the smartest
decision so it's gonna be
very interesting what they do with both
these guys because depending on you know
how you wake up on what side of the bed
you can decide oh I want to extend these
guys forever or yeah you know what the
best way to build the team is to not
give a ton of resources to a quarterback
who has been in the league for a long
time and been more bad than good and a
running back who is very good but the
running back position is not really
where the priorities should be in 2020
yeah I mean my guess would be your
franchise tag Derrick Henry you see what
he does this year before you make a
longer-term decision and then you just
see what the market is for Ryan
Tannehill and if somebody decides to
offer him 30 million a year you say see
you later we'll go signed Phillip Rivers
who is also a CAA client see look that
and then weíll have enough time to get
into this the fact that CA represents GM
John Robinson yes it's a conflict of
interest on the surface but it's not
like they're taking the money out of
John Robinson's pocket they're not
representing John Robinson in the same
negotiate they're not going head-to-head
the fact that they have that
relationship though you know there's
only so far they can push it without
without making him mad and that's just
part of the the delicate reality that
that goes along with being able to
represent both players and general
managers and coaches in the NFL
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports